Albrecht Durer was a Renaissance artist.
The Renaissance was a rediscovery of art, architecture,...
...and philosophy of Ancient Greece and Rome.
People during the Renaissance were also really interested in studying nature...
...and learning all they could from the natural world.
Artists like Albrecht Durer made many drawings of animals and plants.
Remember, this was before photography was invented,...
...if you wanted to look at an animal,...
...you either had to have the animal in front of you,...
...or you had to have a drawing of the animal.
Albrecht Durer filled his sketchbooks with drawings of animals he had observed.
Imagine how difficult this might have been.
You can't exactly ask an animal to sit still while you draw them, can you?